I'm Joel Blackstock and I'm here with Peter Dunlap or Peter T. Dunlap as your website says, who is a clinical psychologist also doing research and philosophy in the area of community transformation and spiritual leadership. So you're another Pacifica grad that we found. Did I miss anything or say any of that wrong? Let's see. Well, you used some words to describe me. I don't know that I would use, but I kind of liked them anyhow. And did you- Well, it's okay if other people call you a philosopher, but if you call yourself a philosopher, that's where you kind of walk. That's my rule of thumb.
我是乔尔·布莱克斯托克，今天和我在一起的是彼得·邓拉普，或者像你网站上写的彼得·T·邓拉普。他是一位临床心理学家，同时也在社区转型和精神领导力领域进行研究和哲学探讨。所以你是我们找到的另一位帕西菲卡（Pacifica）毕业生。我有什么遗漏或者说错的地方吗？让我想想。嗯，你用了一些词来形容我，我不知道自己会不会用这些词，但我还是挺喜欢的。还有你——嗯，别人叫你哲学家没关系，但如果你自己称自己为哲学家，那你就有点越界了。这是我的经验法则。
I do have a degree in philosophy, and I have stuck with the practice of study. So who knows? I think that'll be for other philosophers to decide. It's okay for me to do it, but unless you want to kind of have like a neck beard and some sort of strange you know antiquated antiquated hat and i don't know i would have had a beard david tasey has a quote in one of his books where he's talking about one of the students he's like talking about different archetypes and he was like he was one of those people who uh spoke with a strange accent who he didn't come by honestly and would wear you know red leather and robes and you know when i would
我确实有哲学学位，而且我一直坚持研究。所以谁知道呢？我想这得由其他哲学家来定夺。我自己这么说没关系，但除非你想留那种“颈胡”，戴某种奇怪的、过时的帽子——我不知道，我本来应该留胡子的。大卫·塔西（David Tasey）在他的一本书里引用过一段话，他在谈论他的一个学生时，提到了不同的原型。他说那个人说话带着一种奇怪的口音，那种口音不是他自然形成的，而且他会穿红色的皮衣和长袍。你知道，当我在课堂上
speak in class he would rub his beard and and like sigh deeply and earnestly it's just like you just have this palpable image of this person who's like well i'm a philosopher or a powerful magus or you know whatever is going on on that in that guy's mind that you're in your uh you know philosophy class with and in college i remember those type and i was uh both intimidated and envious at the same time yeah there is something that's kind of enviable about that kind of confidence of just doing yourself i mean not no shade it's just uh no no there was one um, when I was in school, there was like a guy, you know, that always like was trying to return to tradition or whatever. Of course, the traditions were not ones that he came from and he had, you know, like thick, uh, leather pads on his, you know, just looked like he had approximation of, he was dressing like an approximation of what he thought people did at Oxford in the 1700s or something and um he uh it was kind of like a rainy day it's funny something and he was like oh the good English weather and it was like you're from Ohio like you know I'm from Northern California you know um other than that being harder to be any further off the beaten path with what is happening in the world today.
发言时，他会揉着胡子，深深地、严肃地叹气。你脑海中会浮现出这样一个人的形象：他好像在说“嗯，我是一位哲学家，或者一位强大的法师”，或者不管那个家伙脑子里在想什么。在大学里，我和你一起上哲学课时，我记得这类人。我当时既感到被威慑，又感到嫉妒。是的，那种自信确实令人羡慕，就是那种做自己的自信。我是说，我没有贬低的意思，只是……不，不，有一个人，我在学校的时候，有个家伙总是试图回归传统什么的。当然，那些传统并不是他出身的传统。他穿着厚厚的皮垫，看起来就像是在模仿他认为1700年代牛津人穿的那种衣服。那天是个雨天，很有趣，他说：“哦，这美好的英国天气。”而他其实来自俄亥俄州。你知道，我来自北加州，你知道……除此之外，在当今世界发生的事情中，很难再找到比这更偏离主流的地方了。
California is kind of its own thing. We are kind of our own thing. Yeah, exactly. Did you call me a Pacifica graduate? Didn't you? Or alumni? Did I say graduate? I'm sorry. I had gone through a lot of times when we're trying to find interesting people, you'll find a certain research institute or something that if somebody is a member, then their work is going to be interesting. So you're trying to find good guests. But the Pacific alums was, I think, how I found you. Or not alums, but faculty was how I found you. Yeah.
加州本身就是个独特的存在。我们确实有自己的特色。是的，完全正确。你刚才叫我帕西菲卡毕业生，对吧？或者校友？我说的是毕业生吗？抱歉。我在寻找有趣的人时经历了很多次，你会发现某个研究机构，如果某人是其中的成员，那么他们的工作通常会很有趣。所以你是在努力寻找好的嘉宾。但我认为我是通过帕西菲卡的校友找到你的。或者不是校友，而是教职员工。是的。
And I started to read about your work. I'm the co-chair of the clinical psychology program at Pacifica. And we have a good time exploring a bunch of stuff. And maybe we'll get into that some just now. Yeah, I'd love to hear about your work. Oh, goodness. Well, my work is as a clinical psychologist where I work a lot with couples and individuals. I help young adults find their calling and I'm really interested in the way in which we've problematically developed our
我开始阅读你的作品。我是帕西菲卡临床心理学项目的联合主席。我们在一起探索很多东西，玩得很开心。也许我们现在可以深入探讨一下。是的，我很想听听你的工作。哦，天哪。嗯，我的工作是一名临床心理学家，我经常与夫妻和个人合作。我帮助年轻人找到他们的使命，我非常关注我们如何以一种有问题的方式发展了我们的
thinking to the neglect of our feeling and so I do a whole lot of work helping people become rational by Acting to feeling that feeling it We are rationality is dependent on really having access to a normal range of feeling That's one of the makes us able to you know, move around in the world and not bump into things too badly. Yeah, a lot of times when I am working with supervision candidates or doing a consultation group, you've got therapists that somebody says something that, you know, clearly, you know, is the voice of an inner critic or, you know, an oppressive voice in society or something that's
思维，却忽视了我们的感受。所以我做了大量工作，帮助人们通过行动去感受，从而变得理性。我们的理性确实依赖于拥有正常的感受范围。这就是让我们能够在这个世界上走动，而不至于撞到东西的原因。是的，很多时候当我与督导候选人一起工作或进行咨询小组时，会有治疗师提到某件事，那显然是内心批判者的声音，或者是社会中某种压迫性的声音，或者其他什么
not theirs, but they're doubling down on some position that's unhealthy. And the nature of the more cognitive therapist is to get into a debate club with them. And it's like, no, no, no, that feeling is not coming from their brain. It's coming from their heart. If you just push that into their body and make them sit with that for a few minutes, they're going to realize that they don't believe that. And then it feels icky. You know, if you debate them, then they're even more cut off from their body. They're even more dug in. You'll never get it. You know, just, just take people at face value that they believe what they believe, even when you know that that didn't really healthy or their body, they're even more dug in. You'll never get it. Just take people at face value that they believe what they believe, even when you know that that isn't really healthy or not
不是他们自己的声音，但他们却在坚持某种不健康的立场。而认知治疗师的本能是和他们进行辩论。但事实是，不，不，不，那种感觉不是来自他们的大脑，而是来自他们的内心。如果你只是把那种感觉推向他们的身体，让他们在那儿坐一会儿，他们就会意识到他们并不相信那个观点。然后那种感觉会变得很糟糕。你知道，如果你和他们辩论，他们会更加与自己的身体隔绝，更加固执。你永远无法说服他们。你知道，就按人们所说的去理解他们，即使你知道那并不健康，或者那甚至不是
what they believe. And if you can push them into the psychosoma, their body will tell them something that you're not going to get to through their ears and their brain. I like that strategy. There's some faith that it's really possible to have in each person and to help their best self come forward with just some kind loving very very direct yeah and so what you're you do the clinical psychology program there um which pacifica is one of the i mean i think one of the last you know deaf psychology you know uh only universities around uh it's an interesting place and then you also have some other work you've done outside of that do you mind talking about any of the works that you do with kind of politics transformation creativity
他们真正相信的。如果你能把他们推向身心层面，他们的身体会告诉他们一些你通过耳朵和大脑无法传达的东西。我喜欢这个策略。对每个人都有某种信念，并用某种友善、直接的方式帮助他们展现出最好的自己，这是可能的。是的，所以你在那里负责临床心理学项目……帕西菲卡是最后几个（如果不是唯一一个）教授深度心理学的大学之一……这是一个有趣的地方。除了这些，你还做过其他工作吗？你介意谈谈你在政治、转型、创造力方面的工作吗？
community well I come from a political family and my my dad was a very committed liberal progressive back in the 60s and 70s I saw your George McGovern button and 60s headband. That was pretty cool. The picture of you in braces. You still got him? Yeah, I think this is a different one than in the picture you're referencing. Okay, yeah. In my junior high school, I started a George McGovern for President Club
社区方面，我来自一个政治家庭。我父亲在60和70年代是一位非常坚定的自由进步派。我看到了你的乔治·麦戈文（George McGovern）徽章和60年代的发带。那真的很酷。还有你戴着背带的照片。你还留着它们吗？是的，我想这和你提到的照片里的那条不一样。好的，是的。在初中时，我发起了一个“乔治·麦戈文竞选总统俱乐部”，
and got in a little bit of trouble for it from the principal. He was rather friendly and he knew my family and my dad and he let me off the hook. But he said, you know, because you started the George McGovern for president club, some mother is knocking on my door and she wants to start the John Birch for President Club. And that was a different time back in 72. But since then, I just really see the way we liberals and progressives have really not known how to bend the narrative of our time. And we've had a lot of success, but right now we've had so much failure since really since reagan that since uh his narrative about everybody for themselves has taken over and um we we live in desperate times in need of some larger narrative a year ago president obama asked us
并因此惹了一点麻烦。校长很友好，他认识我的家人和我父亲，所以他放了我一马。但他对我说：“你知道，因为你发起了乔治·麦戈文竞选总统俱乐部，有位母亲在敲我的门，她想发起‘约翰·伯奇竞选总统俱乐部’。”那是在72年，那是不同的时代。但从那以后，我真的看到了我们自由派和进步派是如何不知道如何扭转我们时代的叙事。我们曾取得过很多成功，但自里根以来，我们遭遇了太多的失败。自从他那种“各人自扫门前雪”的叙事占据主导地位后，我们生活在绝望的时代，需要一种更宏大的叙事。一年前，奥巴马总统问我们：
what common story could we tell that would hold us all together and move us to the future? And I think that's the work of depth psychologists is to learn how to tell the stories that would hold us together. Well, historically, you know, that part of the alchemical process of letting go, you know, dissolving something to get to the, that isn't working anymore to get to the true, you know, golden side is not something that isn't working anymore to get to the true golden side is not something that works very well politically, especially in America. I mean, crisis of confidence speech is what thought of as the biggest failure politically. And it's really just Carter being like, hey, I don't know if our mythology works anymore. Maybe it does, but could we all sit and wonder
“我们能讲述什么共同的故事，将我们团结在一起并推动我们走向未来？”我认为这就是深度心理学家的工作，即学习如何讲述那些能将我们团结在一起的故事。嗯，从历史上看，你知道，炼金术过程中那种放手、溶解不再起作用的东西以达到真正的、金色的那一面的过程，在政治上并不奏效，尤其是在美国。我的意思是，“信心危机”演讲被认为是政治上最大的失败。而那其实只是卡特在说：“嘿，我不知道我们的神话是否还管用。也许管用，但我们能不能坐下来思考一下
if we need a new myth? And no, man, we won't. Stop. Stop making me feel stuff. When you sit and wait for a new myth, I think what happens is people get afraid because they don't want to hang out in between stories. And so that's when authoritarianism uh becomes welcomed we we welcome the aggressive uh male dominated type of authoritarianism that um really controls people from the outside and so uh in order to let some new myth arise um we actually have to remember the value of caring for one another and putting each other first. And that comes with a level of sacrifice and duty that none of us quite know how to do well enough right now. And I think that's on all of us. Well, and I think you're saying it causes anxiety to have to wait for the new myth. You're also telling people that, you know,
我们是否需要一个新的神话？”不，伙计，我们不会。停下。别再让我产生那种感觉了。当你坐下来等待一个新的神话时，我认为人们会感到恐惧，因为他们不想停留在故事与故事之间的空档期。所以这就是威权主义受到欢迎的时候。我们欢迎那种咄咄逼人的、男性主导的威权主义，它确实从外部控制着人们。因此，为了让新的神话出现，我们实际上必须记住关爱彼此、将他人放在首位的价值。这伴随着一种牺牲和责任，而我们现在谁都不知道该如何做得足够好。我认为这取决于我们所有人。嗯，我认为你说的是，等待新神话的过程会引起焦虑。你也在告诉人们，
what they're identified with in the past is not right, you know, which can be a huge opportunity for growth. It's hard to tell that to a patient in a room, you know, you have to creep around that for several sessions and maybe use a metaphor or a story or, you know, in order to make that something that the psyche can tolerate that isn't threatening and overwhelming and re-traumatizing, but it's the person can see it as an opportunity for growth. I don't know how you do that with
他们过去所认同的东西是不对的，这可能是一个巨大的成长机会。在治疗室里告诉病人这一点很难，你知道，你必须在几次会谈中小心翼翼地绕过它，也许使用隐喻或故事，以便让心灵能够容忍它，而不感到威胁、压倒性或再次受到创伤，但这是让当事人将其视为成长机会的方法。我不知道你如何对800万人做到这一点。
8 million people. I barely know how to do that with one person in a therapy room. See, this is where groups become so very important and interesting because there are social change organizations that are working on this every day, all day long. There are hundreds and thousands and tens of thousands of really good people working on this from the left and the right. There's an organization called Braver Angels that has chapters around the country that sit people who are left-leaning
我几乎不知道如何在治疗室里对一个人做到这一点。看，这就是群体变得如此重要和有趣的地方，因为有一些社会变革组织每天都在为此努力。有成千上万的好人正在从左翼和右翼对此进行研究。有一个叫“勇敢天使”（Braver Angels）的组织，在全国各地都有分会，他们让倾向左翼的人
and people who are right-leaning down at the same table and help them learn to talk to one another. And I think there's an opportunity for psychotherapists to get more involved such that that storytelling that we do know how to help one person at a time tell becomes more accessible in larger group contexts. I think that's part of the vision, the original vision of psychology by our founders. They really wanted to see psychology become the narrative used, the means used in every institution, whether they be political or religious or humanitarian.
和倾向右翼的人坐在同一张桌子旁，帮助他们学习如何与对方交谈。我认为心理治疗师有机会更多地参与进来，这样我们知道如何帮助一个人讲述的故事，在更大的群体环境中变得更容易被接受。我认为这是我们创始人最初的心理学愿景的一部分。他们真的希望看到心理学成为在每个机构中使用的叙事和手段，无论是政治、宗教还是人道主义机构。
Just by sitting down and talking to one another and finding our shared humanity, it really becomes possible to bridge the differences. But it's going to take something at a more organized level, given the level of polarization that's dominating us now. Well, but what you just said is that you want people wanting to see psychology become kind of the future and outside of somebody that, you know, has a very literal belief in, um, some sort of religious practice or something they'd like to see society centered around. I think most people would agree with you on what that is, where most people would fight is when you start to say what psychology is, because on an individual level, psychology is the class that I had to sit through where they said, all right, you know, it ego, but that's outdated. Jung cognitive, you know, collective unconscious, if you get him at all, and then here's the behaviorists and then here's the cognitive therapy. And it's not that threatening of a concept, but when you get to a society level
只要坐下来交谈，找到我们共同的人性，弥合分歧就真的成为可能。但在目前这种两极分化主导的情况下，这需要更组织化的层面。嗯，但你刚才说的是，你希望人们看到心理学成为未来，而不是像某些人那样，对某种宗教实践有非常字面的信仰，或者他们希望社会围绕某种东西展开。我想大多数人会同意你的看法，但大多数人会争论的地方在于你开始定义什么是心理学时。因为在个人层面上，心理学是我不得不坐着听的课程，他们说：“好吧，你知道，自我（ego），但那已经过时了。荣格、认知、集体潜意识（如果你能理解的话），然后是行为主义者，然后是认知疗法。”这并不是一个令人威胁的概念，但当你上升到社会层面时，
and you start talking about psychology, you're talking about who I am and how I think, which is not something that most people want to know, or they would fight kind of with you about how people work and what the nature is, especially when you're of humanity is especially when you're right. And, and so you, you get, you know, you're talking about Reagan and Thatcher coming in and that, that kind of a period of austerity and, um, you know, disbanding community resources to focus more on kind of, you know, national, um, you know, personal freedom and national, um, uh mythology, essentially. But one of the things that did is it pushed psychotherapy incredibly cognitive
当你开始谈论心理学时，你谈论的是“我是谁”以及“我如何思考”，这不是大多数人想知道的，或者他们会因为人性是如何运作的以及本质是什么而与你争论，尤其是当你正确的时候。所以，你谈到了里根和撒切尔上台，那个紧缩时期，以及解散社区资源以更多地关注个人自由和国家神话。但其中一件事是，它将心理治疗推向了极其认知的方向，
in a way that it still has not recovered from. I think you're right. I mean, and for two reasons, I think. I mean, one, it was just appealing to that myth to say what I think is all that I am. There's nothing else to me. I really am the simple. I need to get the line needs to go up. I need to have a bigger army. I need to have a bigger bank account. We are all just what we
以至于它至今仍未恢复。我想你是对的。我的意思是，原因有二。第一，诉诸那种神话，说“我所想的就是我的全部”，这很有吸引力。我没有其他东西。我确实很简单。我需要让曲线向上，我需要更大的军队，我需要更大的银行账户。我们都只是我们所做的，
do, not what we feel. And so hierarchical thinking, and, you know, that's a very cognitive construct. But then also, you just had an explosion of corporations that kind of started to corporatize academia and healthcare in a way that those entities have not recovered from. And cognitive therapy is very useful. If my insurance company is going to say you've got six sessions to cure PTSD or else you need to just take medicine, cognitive therapy is great there because there's not insight and growth and these bigger things that are harder to turn into a number. I don't know. I'd be interested in what you think. Yeah, well, you're working on several things at once, and let me see if I can help us untangle them. Certainly, cognitive behavioral therapy has its place. There's a process going on over the course of the 20th century that we could describe as the democratization of access to psychotherapy that
而不是我们所感受的。所以等级思维，那是一个非常认知的结构。但随后，你又有了大量企业开始将学术界和医疗保健企业化，以至于这些实体至今仍未恢复。认知疗法非常有用。如果我的保险公司说你有六次会谈来治愈创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），否则你就得吃药，那么认知疗法在那里很棒，因为没有洞察力、成长和这些更大的、难以转化为数字的东西。我不知道。我很想听听你的想法。是的，你同时在处理几件事，让我看看能不能帮你理清它们。当然，认知行为疗法（CBT）有其地位。在20世纪的过程中，有一个过程我们可以描述为心理治疗获取途径的民主化，
was once only available to the rich is now becoming increasingly available to more people. So be it. The bad news is cognitive behavioral therapy really narrows down what it means to be human problematically from what I can tell. Now somebody sitting here from a cognitive behavioral perspective, they and I would have an argument about that, and that's fine. It's good to have open debate about that. Well, some of them, they say they're doing CBT, but when you talk to them
曾经只有富人才能享受的治疗，现在正变得越来越普及。那就这样吧。坏消息是，据我所知，认知行为疗法在定义“人意味着什么”方面存在问题，它缩小了范围。现在，如果有人从认知行为的角度坐在这里，我和他会有一场争论，这没关系。对这个问题进行公开辩论是件好事。嗯，他们中的一些人说他们在做CBT，但当你和他们谈论
about what they're doing, it becomes very clearly that they've just realized how to use the CBT framework language to turn into relational therapy or to turn into psychodynamic therapy or even more of a Jungian you know self-discovered process when you listen to what they're actually doing in the room it isn't what Beck says to do in the CBT book you know that's what the space therapy is starting to uncover that actual what we're learning from science what we're learning from the research into psychotherapy uh is that that it is two human beings sitting together re-establishing the primary attachment links that make growth and being
他们在做什么时，很明显他们只是意识到如何使用CBT框架语言将其转化为关系疗法，或转化为心理动力学疗法，甚至更多地转化为荣格式的自我发现过程。当你听他们在房间里实际做的事情时，那并不是贝克（Beck）在CBT书中所说的。你知道，这就是空间疗法开始揭示的东西。我们从科学中学到的，从心理治疗研究中学到的，是两个人在坐在一起，重建基本的依恋联系，这使得成长和对学习保持开放成为可能，而这一切都基于关系。现在，这在政治上意味着什么？
open to learning possible and it's all based on relationship now what does that imply out there in the political um i i think what it implies is some need to go very slowly and not imagine that we're going to suddenly get people that are extremely different from us to the table. I don't think we need to create one big tent that everybody's comfortable in. I think that we need to rebuild things a little more slowly than that. And each one of us will do that differently. You're doing it in the way by holding these podcasts. I do it by working with people on the political left who really are the ones holding my community together. They're the ones out there finding candidates to run for the city council and
我认为这意味着需要非常缓慢地进行，不要想象我们能突然让与我们极其不同的人坐到桌边。我不认为我们需要创造一个每个人都感到舒适的大帐篷。我认为我们需要比那更缓慢地重建事物。我们每个人都会以不同的方式做到这一点。你通过举办这些播客来做到这一点。我通过与政治左翼的人合作来做到这一点，他们确实是维系我社区的人。他们是在外面寻找市议会候选人、
raising money and putting up yard signs. And so I like to sit down with them and find out how they're doing, what level of distress they're experiencing. Are they lonely? What would happen if they got attention from each other and not only held meetings that were based on who's going to put the yard signs up next week, but really paid attention to each other in a creative and more psychologically focused manner. And in that way, psychology is not just psychotherapy. Whether you go behavioral or cognitive development or emotion focused or psychodynamic all of those are psychology but psychology is much bigger than psychotherapy it's much bigger yeah it has to do with how we treat one another and that we can learn to apply psychology in our social change organizations to make them more of a
筹集资金和张贴院子标语的人。所以我喜欢和他们坐下来，了解他们的情况，他们正在经历什么程度的痛苦。他们感到孤独吗？如果他们能从彼此那里得到关注，而不仅仅是举行基于“下周谁去贴标语”的会议，而是以一种创造性的、更关注心理的方式关注彼此，会发生什么？通过这种方式，心理学不仅仅是心理治疗。无论你是行为主义、认知发展、情绪聚焦还是心理动力学，所有这些都是心理学，但心理学比心理治疗大得多。它大得多。是的，它与我们如何对待彼此有关，我们可以学习在社会变革组织中应用心理学，使它们成为一个
home to make them a place where people can go to experience belonging and connection and to have that from the center of activity that enables us to strengthen our social change organizations and bring about more accelerated change, specifically around climate change. I think that is the primary crisis that's driving all of the other horrors of our time. And I think one of the ironies with climate change is that we evolved to understand fairly simple systems. I mean, some of the smartest people can understand kind of maybe five layers of cause and effect in a complex system. Most people see one or two, you know, I felt bad when
家，使它们成为人们可以去体验归属感和联系的地方，并从活动的中心获得这一点，这使我们能够加强我们的社会变革组织，并带来更快速的变革，特别是在气候变化方面。我认为这是驱动我们时代所有其他恐怖的主要危机。我认为气候变化的一个讽刺之处在于，我们进化到能够理解相当简单的系统。我的意思是，一些最聪明的人能够理解复杂系统中大约五层因果关系。大多数人只看到一两层，你知道，“我感觉不好，当
I was in that store. Well, you got a phone call that was bad. Now I'm just going to go ahead and associate that whole thing with feeling not good. You know, we don't, we don't really want to interrogate those systems and pick them apart. It just, it was evolutionarily beneficial for us to not have, I mean, we weren't supposed to be supercomputers modeling incredibly complicated, you know, global phenomenon, or just kind of supposed to be like, red berry tastes good. Green berry makes you die. Don't do that. And now we're sitting with something that is so infinitely complicated, by the time everybody can readily apparently see the problem, it maybe is too late. Well, it is too late. Now, we don't know how bad it'll get. We don't know how far the environment will deteriorate. We don't know what level of social organization we will maintain. Let's cross our fingers and hope we
我在那家店里的时候。”好吧，你接到了一个糟糕的电话。现在我只是要把这一切与感觉不好联系起来。你知道，我们并不真的想审视这些系统并将它们拆解。进化上，我们不这样做是有利的。我的意思是，我们本不应该成为模拟极其复杂的全球现象的超级计算机，我们只是应该像“红浆果味道好，绿浆果让你死，别吃那个”这样。而现在我们正面临着如此无限复杂的事情，等到每个人都能明显看到问题时，也许已经太晚了。嗯，确实太晚了。现在，我们不知道情况会变得多糟。我们不知道环境会恶化到什么程度。我们不知道我们将维持什么样的社会组织。让我们交叉手指，希望我们
really do have a chance. But what you're saying is really important. And we don't need suddenly people to handle much greater complexity. We need a story that holds all people together. We need a story that holds people together, regardless of how much complexity they are comfortable with. A good story that's true. The story has to be true. It can't go around blaming other people for things they didn't do. So if history feels good, Peter, what are you trying to tell me here?
真的还有机会。但你所说的是非常重要的。我们不需要人们突然处理更复杂的事务。我们需要一个将所有人团结在一起的故事。我们需要一个将人们团结在一起的故事，无论他们对复杂性的适应程度如何。一个真实的好故事。故事必须是真实的。它不能到处指责别人做过他们没做过的事。所以如果历史感觉很好，彼得，你在这里想告诉我什么？
Well, we want a story that creates space for everybody to belong. But I'm good and they're bad. So you're kind of making me feel not special. You know, it's okay if you really need to blame people.
嗯，我们想要一个为每个人创造归属空间的故事。但“我是好的，他们是坏的”。所以你有点让我觉得我不特别了。你知道，如果你真的需要指责别人，那没关系。
I'll say, you know, you must be really mad tell me more. I think good storytelling does that. People used to sit around the campfire or in their village centers, and they used to dance and sing in their churches. They would listen to the minister, and they would all have a place where they had a deep experience that they belonged to that group, and it would be filled with feeling. And that's something that we can recreate through the right type of community leadership that has upstanding in psychological awareness. That's why I was wondering what you'd think of those Adam Curtis movies. I don't know if you got a chance to look at him.
我会说，你知道，你一定很生气，多告诉我一些。我认为好的叙事能做到这一点。人们过去常围坐在篝火旁或村中心，他们会在教堂里跳舞和唱歌。他们会听牧师讲道，他们都会有一个地方，在那里他们有深刻的归属感，并且充满情感。这是我们可以通过具有心理意识的社区领导力来重建的东西。这就是为什么我想知道你对那些亚当·柯蒂斯（Adam Curtis）的电影怎么看。我不知道你有没有机会看。
But I mean, what I've seen in my lifetime and i mean i don't go back to the 70s you know i'm born in 87 but what i've seen is and it kind of switches i mean the left and the right go through a period of um you know kind of being more uh populous but there's what in america what i've been forced to pick between in every election is a group of people that's telling a story that is compelling and interesting, but also a lie that isn't helpful and a misdiagnosis of the problem, you know, usually scapegoating a group of people. And then you have another party that is refusing to tell any story at all. Like they're telling me to go to a website and memorize facts, or this is just right, or you should do it and it's like
但我的意思是，在我的一生中——我的意思是，我没有回到70年代，你知道，我出生于87年——但我所看到的是，它在切换。我的意思是，左派和右派都经历了一个更加民粹主义的时期，但在美国，我在每次选举中被迫选择的是一群人，他们讲述的故事既引人入胜又有趣，但也是一个无益的谎言，是对问题的误诊，通常是把一群人当作替罪羊。然后你有另一个政党，他们拒绝讲述任何故事。就像他们让我去一个网站背诵事实，或者这才是正确的，或者你应该这样做，这就像
please stop like and can i mean that's what you want to sit these people down and be like look the thing they teach you the first day of law school is that it doesn't matter what's true what is relevant is can you tell a story that the jury it makes sense to them and so you know when i'm in college and and there all this, the beginning of, you know, you start to hook, you know, old, basically old people into email for the first time and Obama's getting to be president and there's these interesting, you know, artifacts coming out of that. But it's like, you know, when I'm sitting there and I'm, you know, 89 and I, you know, the rural electrification act brought a light to my house or whatever. And somebody'm, you know, 89 and I, you know, the Royal Electrification Act brought a light to my house or whatever. And somebody says, well, Obama is a Muslim hologram.
请停下。我的意思是，这就是你想让这些人坐下来，然后说：“看，法学院第一天教你的就是，真相是什么并不重要，重要的是你能否讲述一个对陪审团来说有意义的故事。”所以，你知道，当我在大学时，那是开始，你知道，你开始第一次让老年人使用电子邮件，奥巴马即将成为总统，有一些有趣的文物从中产生。但就像，你知道，当我坐在那里，我89岁，我，你知道，农村电气化法案给我的房子带来了光明，或者其他什么。然后有人说，嗯，奥巴马是一个穆斯林全息图。
That's a compelling story to me. OK, we need another one, too. I don't think I'm not interested in upsetting people. If that's the story someone needs to believe, then God bless them. Really, truly. We only need to tell a story that brings a few people closer together. It won't take many. We need to tell a story. I think that's it. It's going to be a patchwork, like a quilt. It's going to be a community of small communities, not a giant community. Yes. It's not a big tent. We don't need a big tent. We're never going to get a big tent.
那对我来说是一个引人入胜的故事。好的，我们也需要另一个。我不感兴趣让人们心烦意乱。如果那是某人需要相信的故事，那么上帝保佑他们。真的，确实。我们只需要讲述一个能让几个人更紧密地团结在一起的故事。不需要很多人。我们需要讲述一个故事。我想就是这样。它将是一块拼布，像被子一样。它将是一个小社区的社区，而不是一个巨大的社区。是的。这不是一个大帐篷。我们不需要大帐篷。我们永远不会得到一个大帐篷。
What we need is to bring enough people from the near right together with enough people from the near left, together with enough far lefties with medium lefties, wherever the breach is within the left, oppressives and liberals, whatever the breach is between the moderates, whatever, there's a current breach inside the Republican party. That's profound. It's just profound, the breach within the Republican party. And a part of me could say, you know, go ahead, you guys fight it out. I'm going to sit in the sidelines. But I really think that would be a mistake on my part. That breach within the Republican Party is a breach inside me. And there's some intense emotional pull toward the deepest form of closing boundaries around small groups because of how scared and angry those people are and that should
我们需要做的是将足够多的近右翼人士与足够多的近左翼人士聚集在一起，再加上足够多的极左翼人士和中左翼人士，无论左翼内部的裂痕在哪里，压迫者和自由派，无论温和派之间的裂痕是什么，无论如何，共和党内部目前存在一种裂痕。那是深刻的。共和党内部的裂痕非常深刻。我的一部分可能会说，你知道，去吧，你们自己去争论吧。我要坐在场边。但我真的认为那将是我的一个错误。共和党内部的裂痕是我内部的裂痕。由于那些人是多么害怕和愤怒，有一种强烈的、向着围绕小群体关闭边界的最深层形式的情感拉力，这应该
be respected and considered well i think they're scared and angry on you know kind of the liberal middle left too it's just they're scared and angry of a different thing i agree i mean i think the appeal of i mean i don't really think one i don't know i mean i think the appeal of like fox news is that like you know your cultural star is not waning it's not that like your your aging and your perspective is less relevant it's not that the world has changed since you were 13 it's just that the world is bad everyone's bad and you're good so just get really angry about this and this becomes this kind of addictive thing whereas it seems like cnn what they're saying is like oh look you know you don't need to change anything you don't need to change anything. You don't need to do anything different, you know, other than maybe vote.
得到尊重和考虑。嗯，我认为自由派中左翼也感到害怕和愤怒，只是他们害怕和愤怒的东西不同。我同意，我的意思是，我认为福克斯新闻的吸引力在于，你知道，你的文化明星并没有减弱，并不是说你老了，你的观点不再那么重要了，并不是说世界在你13岁之后就变了，只是世界很糟糕，每个人都很糟糕，而你是好的，所以就对此感到非常愤怒，这变成了一种令人上瘾的东西。而CNN似乎在说，哦，看，你知道，你不需要改变任何事情，你不需要改变任何事情。你不需要做任何不同的事情，你知道，除了也许投票。
But like this, just know that you're correct. You have the right opinion. You're looking down on the right people. And while you're looking down on the right people, you're on the right side of history and you're not going to be embarrassed and you're not going to look foolish. And that's kind of the itch that that scratches. So we know that systems close boundaries using stories. And we know that hate feels good. And the purpose of hate is to close boundaries around identity groups. We know all of that.
但就像这样，只要知道你是正确的。你有正确的观点。你在俯视正确的人。当你俯视正确的人时，你站在历史正确的一边，你不会感到尴尬，也不会看起来很愚蠢。这就是它所抓挠的痒处。所以我们知道系统利用故事来关闭边界。我们知道仇恨感觉很好。仇恨的目的是围绕身份群体关闭边界。我们知道所有这些。
So those of us that are trying to create something post-ideological, that's where psychology comes in. Psychology is something that takes place in the clinic or the posh private practice office uh that's a psychology but psychology also applies where those where any narrowing of the truth can be addressed and my my focus is i want to address the narrowing of the truth that takes place within the political left. That's where I have placed the lever to move the world. I want the political left to have more tolerance for the truth. And we... That would be nice.
所以我们这些试图创造后意识形态事物的人，这就是心理学发挥作用的地方。心理学是发生在诊所或高档私人诊所办公室里的东西，那是心理学，但心理学也适用于任何可以解决真相缩减的地方。我的重点是，我想解决政治左翼内部发生的真相缩减。这就是我放置杠杆来推动世界的地方。我希望政治左翼对真相有更多的容忍度。而我们……那会很好。
We on the left are not that good at the truth. We're not that good at science. We make all sorts of silly claims about how we're the ones that are devoted to science. And we're only really interested in the science we can cherry pick right off the low hanging fruit that already aligns with the ways we think. And what we need is a triple down commitment to a full range of science. And it will be very humbling because of the reasons you're listing around the way we tell ourselves stories that are arrogant where does that aversion to science not it's not even aversion it's like this ambivalent relationship that the kind of moderate you know middle left seems to have a
我们左派在真相方面并不那么擅长。我们不擅长科学。我们做出各种愚蠢的声明，说我们是致力于科学的人。而我们实际上只对那些我们可以从低垂的果实中挑选出来的、已经与我们思考方式一致的科学感兴趣。我们需要的是对全方位科学的加倍承诺。这将是非常谦卑的，因为你列出的原因，关于我们讲述傲慢故事的方式。这种对科学的厌恶来自哪里？甚至不是厌恶，这就像那种温和的中左翼似乎对科学有一种矛盾的关系，
science now where it's like i mean they had a like i don't know if it was a campaign or something there's a bumper sticker where everybody had this i effing love science things and you follow their linkedin or their facebook profile just a little bit and when they're done posting about harry potter and and star wars they're yelling at somebody who posted a research study because it doesn't agree with their worldview well we live in really troubled times and so so it's so tempting to find fault. I love science. It does not mean I watched Neil deGrasse Tyson one time. I just don't know what that means.
现在就像，我的意思是，他们有一个，我不知道是不是竞选活动或其他什么，有一个保险杠贴纸，每个人都有这个“我他妈的爱科学”的东西，你稍微关注一下他们的LinkedIn或Facebook个人资料，当他们发完关于哈利·波特和星球大战的内容后，他们就在对某人咆哮，因为那个人发布了一项研究，而该研究与他们的世界观不符。嗯，我们生活在非常动荡的时代，所以寻找过错是如此诱人。我爱科学。这并不意味着我曾经看过尼尔·德格拉塞·泰森（Neil deGrasse Tyson）。我只是不知道那意味着什么。
I know. I know. But here's the thing. What you said earlier about levels of complexity really applies here. That when I am having a bad day, I'm going to be not as open to all of the complexities of what's true around me. One of them is going to get under my skin and I'm going to want to snap at my neighbor. or I'm going to drive too fast on the freeway and be pissed at somebody cutting me off, or I'm going to be a little bored by one of my clients instead of kind, patient, and empathic and direct. So I have real bad days and mostly I have pretty good days. And on the good days, then I don't get surprised by how hard it is to stay open to the full complexities of what's going on around us.
我知道。我知道。但事情是这样的。你之前关于复杂性水平的说法在这里非常适用。当我度过糟糕的一天时，我不会那么开放地接受我周围所有真实的复杂性。其中一个会让我感到不适，我想对邻居发火，或者我在高速公路上开得太快，对切入我车道的人感到愤怒，或者我对我的客户感到有点厌烦，而不是友善、耐心、富有同理心和直接。所以我确实有糟糕的日子，大多数时候我有相当不错的日子。在美好的日子里，我就不会因为保持对周围发生的全部复杂性的开放是多么困难而感到惊讶。
Someone like Rachel Maddow, who I assume still does television broadcasting, though I stopped watching her years ago. I haven't had a cable ever, so I'm watching her years ago. She has... I haven't had a cable ever, so I'm not really sure what the lineup looks like now. They seem to get canceled every other year now, so you got to refresh it. Whether it be her or a dozen others, there's just a way of cherry-picking the facts
像雷切尔·麦多（Rachel Maddow）这样的人，我假设她还在做电视广播，尽管我几年前就不看她了。我从来没有装过有线电视，所以我几年前就不看她了。她有……我从来没有装过有线电视，所以我不太确定现在的阵容是什么样的。他们似乎每隔一年就被取消一次，所以你得刷新一下。无论是她还是其他十几个人，他们只是有一种挑选事实的方式，
and coming up with pretty pat arguments and then displaying contempt for anybody that doesn't go along with that storyline and i don't think people should indulge in contempt right now it's way too risky what but i mean serious question that's a little bit go ahead i'm sorry there's a delay i didn't mean to interrupt you at all. Please finish. Oh, that's okay. All I was saying was we need more humility. Yeah.
并提出相当陈词滥调的论点，然后对任何不赞同该故事情节的人表现出蔑视。我不认为人们现在应该沉溺于蔑视，这太冒险了。但是，我的意思是，严肃的问题，那有点……继续，对不起。有延迟，我完全不想打断你。请继续。哦，没关系。我只是说我们需要更多的谦逊。是的。
And there's nothing harder. Well, there's two questions that I've got there. One is a little bit more theoretical and then one's a little bit more practical. One, are you familiar with John Beebe, the Beebe model of the MBTI? John was on my dissertation committee. And I published a review of his book. And at first I didn't really get the MBI, the Myers-Briggs.
我有两个问题。一个是理论上的，一个是实践上的。第一，你熟悉约翰·比比（John Beebe）的MBTI比比模型吗？约翰在我的论文委员会里。我发表过一篇关于他书的评论。起初我并没有真正理解MBTI，迈尔斯-布里格斯类型指标。
And I was kind of polite to John because of how much he had helped me. And then he caught on that I was only being polite. He nudged me and he said, well, Peter, you know, it's about consciousness. And I go, oh, because he knew I was interested in consciousness. So I started reading closely and studying and I started catching on. It's, it works. It's an excellent system for understanding why I lean this way and you lean that way, how we're different. Well, the BB model of the MBTI specifically tells you that you can use that individual psychology that is studying the inside of you to see how you're going to project that externally. And I think that because you can turn individual psychology or group psychology into a cosmology, basically,
因为约翰帮了我很多，所以我对他很客气。然后他发现我只是在客气。他推了我一下说：“嗯，彼得，你知道，这是关于意识的。”我说：“哦。”因为他知道我对意识感兴趣。所以我开始仔细阅读和研究，我开始明白了。它管用。这是一个理解为什么我倾向于这边，你倾向于那边，我们如何不同的优秀系统。嗯，MBTI的比比模型明确告诉你，你可以使用那种研究你内心的个人心理学来观察你将如何向外投射它。而且我认为，因为你可以将个人心理学或群体心理学转化为宇宙学，基本上，
that seems very useful for being able to understand society. Because like, for example, in the BB model, like I'm, you know, kind of a EI split, you know, I can split between EI and FJ, but every time I've ever taken it, you know, very strong NFJ, INFJ, ENFJ, you know, split, but 100% of my points are in intuition you know I'm just very bad at doing anything that's kind of detail oriented or or a rote memorization hierarchical I'll try and figure out how it works and you know whatever so it's like that gets me in trouble but that's what happens is you know I want to sit with a gray area of everything and look at these sides and whatever but my shadow type is going to be the
这对于理解社会似乎非常有用。因为例如，在比比模型中，我是一个EI分裂，你知道，我可以在EI和FJ之间分裂，但每次我做测试时，你知道，非常强的NFJ，INFJ，ENFJ，你知道，分裂，但我的100%的分数都在直觉上。你知道，我非常不擅长做任何细节导向或死记硬背、等级制度的事情。我会尝试弄清楚它是如何运作的，你知道，无论如何，所以这让我陷入麻烦，但这就是发生的事情，你知道，我想坐在所有事情的灰色地带，看看这些方面，无论如何，但我的阴影类型将是
opposite of that so when i'm in crisis you know like when i'm starting the clinic and i'm working 17 hours a day and you know stuff's going wrong at home and stuff's going wrong at work and i just don't have any more bandwidth then i become extremely black and white and extremely you know judging you know thinking that and it's the opposite of my personality, but I think societies function the same way, you know? I mean, there's a reason that you have kind of a right hierarchical snapback at the end of every kind of, um, you know, introspective, you know, point in history, you know, the eighties come after the seventies for a reason, I think. I think that's right. And here's a way to open it up historically and
相反的。所以当我在危机中时，你知道，就像当我开始诊所时，我每天工作17个小时，你知道，家里出事了，工作出事了，我没有任何带宽了，然后我变得极其黑白分明，极其，你知道，评判，你知道，认为……这是我个性的反面，但我认为社会以同样的方式运作，你知道？我的意思是，这就是为什么在历史的每一个内省点结束时，你都会有一种右翼等级制度的反弹，你知道，80年代出现在70年代之后是有原因的，我想。我想那是对的。这里有一个在历史上打开它的方法，
measure it in terms of hundreds of years. We have the enlightenment that differentiates thinking and sensory experience, and that leads to the scientific and industrial revolutions. Maybe that's a blessing, maybe it's a horror, depending on who you ask and when, certainly it's both. But then what ends up happening is people become so lopsided with thinking and sensing that they lose the moral bearing of feeling and they don't object to colonialism or raping peoples or killing native peoples. When Napoleon goes into Egypt in 1798, I think, and he gets a bunch of prisoners, the prisoners have dark skin and they're Egyptians. And normally what he'd do is he would repatriate prisoners if they were Austrian and white, but instead he mows them down, he butchers them. And so this is a underdeveloped moral function that is haunting us moderns.
以几百年为单位来衡量。我们拥有将思维与感官体验区分开来的启蒙运动，这引领了科学和工业革命。这或许是一种福分，或许是一场灾难，取决于你问谁以及在何时问，当然，两者兼而有之。但随之而来的是，人们在思维和感知上变得如此失衡，以至于失去了情感的道德准则，他们不再反对殖民主义、强奸他人或杀害原住民。我想是在1798年，当拿破仑进入埃及并俘虏了一群人时，这些囚犯皮肤黝黑，是埃及人。通常情况下，如果囚犯是奥地利人或白人，他会遣返他们，但他却将他们扫射屠杀。这是一种困扰着我们现代人的、不发达的道德功能。
And so us in depth psychology are trying to do something about that one person at a time in the clinic. And we have 30 years now into emotion-focused therapy and relational therapy and really using feeling in a creative and powerful way. And in that way, we're working for the whole Western civilization trying to rebalance its lopsided intellect. Now, as soon as you get into the political world, the left becomes utterly blind and indulges in that thinking analysis that you described earlier as going to facts and not telling stories. And so one of the things I do is I really try to help people on the political left reuse the therapy they've been in for their
因此，我们深层心理学界正试图在诊所里通过一个个案例来解决这个问题。我们已经在以情绪为中心的疗法和关系疗法上深耕了30年，真正以创造性和有力的方式运用情感。通过这种方式，我们正在为整个西方文明努力，试图重新平衡其失衡的智力。现在，一旦你进入政治世界，左派就会变得极其盲目，沉溺于你之前描述的那种思维分析，即只关注事实而不讲述故事。因此，我所做的事情之一，就是真正尝试帮助政治左派将他们在个人生活中所接受的治疗经验，
private lives and bring that into their public way of engaging with one another so that we reconstitute feeling as a higher form of intelligence that we use socially. Now, that's something that we need to do to rebalance the typological imbalance that's been taking place for hundreds of years and it's possible to do an adept psychologist can lead the way well and i mean the second part of that practical question when you're talking about the news is like you know in a system can a system that is pretending to be objective because they put the two people that disagree about this thing and the root on either side of the screen and they fight, even though, well, actually there's these other truths all over here and you just pick these two people that
带入到他们彼此互动的公共方式中，以便我们将情感重构为一种我们在社会中使用的更高形式的智慧。这是我们需要做的事情，以重新平衡几百年来一直存在的类型学失衡，这是可以做到的，一位精通的心理学家可以引领方向。我的意思是，当你谈论新闻时，那个实际问题的第二部分是，你知道，在一个系统中，一个假装客观的系统，因为它把对这件事有分歧的两个人放在屏幕的两侧，让他们争吵，尽管实际上这里到处都是其他真相，而你只是挑选了这两个人，
have one difference to pretend that the truth is on, you know, two inches to the left or right of the middle. But like when you have that system and you're you're taking and and every corporation has a because you know we used to say you work for the people if you're on the news the government pays for the news hour and you're not able to go pick a side and work for a corporation you have to be objective if you say something that's a lie you get in trouble and then reagan chips away at those because he kind of wants to tell some stories about iran contra and stuff and then clinton completely says you know you can a lie, you get in trouble. And then Reagan chips away at those because he kind of wants to tell some stories about Iran-Contra and stuff. And then Clinton completely says, you know, you can
只有一个分歧，就假装真相是在中间向左或向右两英寸的地方。但是，当你拥有那个系统，并且你正在……而且每家公司都有一个……因为你知道我们过去常说，如果你在新闻界工作，你就是为人民工作，政府为新闻时段买单，你不能选择立场并为一家公司工作，你必须客观，如果你说了谎，你就会惹上麻烦。然后里根削弱了这些规定，因为他想讲一些关于伊朗门事件之类的故事。然后克林顿完全说，你知道，你可以……如果你说了谎，你就会惹上麻烦。然后里根削弱了这些规定，因为他想讲一些关于伊朗门事件之类的故事。然后克林顿完全说，你知道，你可以
actually own the news station, just go ahead and buy it. So, you know, you've got preparations that there's this whole cycle and you have the same general who's the four-star general in the military who now is sitting on the board of the Lockheed Martin company or, you know, whatever military contractor that goes on the news to say, well, they won't let us. We need to cut loose. We need these bigger bombs. Look at this product. Look what it can do basically to do advertising for a government contractor. And that's, I mean, there's a million different examples of that, but you have this kind of feedback loop of these companies that own an interest in each other, pretending that they're a news company
实际上拥有新闻台，直接买下来就行了。所以，你知道，你拥有这些准备，这是一个完整的循环，你拥有同一个将军，那个军队里的四星上将，现在坐在洛克希德·马丁公司的董事会里，或者，你知道，任何军事承包商，他们上新闻说，好吧，他们不让我们这样做。我们需要放手。我们需要这些更大的炸弹。看看这个产品。看看它能做什么，基本上就是为政府承包商做广告。我的意思是，这样的例子有上百万个，但你有一种反馈循环，这些公司在彼此身上拥有利益，却假装自己是一家新闻公司，
when they're really not. I mean, is there a way to do what you're saying at all under that system? I mean, is the answer just to turn it off and have a conversation with your church or your school or your employees instead of listening to this stuff? I like that idea. The scale that corporations now dominate, the way that the media and government and corporate, private, for-profit corporations, the way those three things are fused together is disastrous. It can't change its mission. I guess what I'm getting at is it cannot change its mission away from profit. You can make a really good point to it. you can have really good people in the organization you can you can basically like they're gonna expand within the limits of what you let them do within regulation but they they can't i mean i was remember as a kid there was like um i think it was nike but
而实际上并非如此。我的意思是，在这个系统下，有没有可能做到你所说的那样？我的意思是，答案只是关掉它，去和你的教会、学校或员工交谈，而不是听这些东西吗？我喜欢这个主意。企业现在统治的规模，媒体、政府和企业——私营的、营利性的公司——这三者融合在一起的方式是灾难性的。它无法改变其使命。我想我想要表达的是，它无法改变其以利润为中心的使命。你可以向它提出一个非常好的观点，你可以在组织中拥有非常优秀的人，你可以……基本上，他们会在你允许的监管范围内扩张，但他们不能……我的意思是，我记得小时候，有，嗯，我想是耐克，但
there was like some big protest that happened on the lawn of the ceo about how they were making all of these um you know shoes for 10 cents an hour and child labor whatever of the CEO about how they're making all of these, you know, shoes for 10 cents an hour and child labor or whatever. And the CEO came out to the protesters and he was like, I agree with you. I don't want to do this. But if I do what you're saying, they'll fire me and they'll put another person there. I'm irrelevant. I'm a cog in this process.
当时在CEO的草坪上发生了一些大规模抗议，关于他们如何以每小时10美分的价格制造所有这些，嗯，你知道，鞋子，以及童工什么的……关于他们如何以每小时10美分的价格制造所有这些，你知道，鞋子，以及童工什么的。CEO走到抗议者面前说，我同意你们的观点。我不想这样做。但如果我按照你们说的做，他们会解雇我，然后换另一个人来。我无关紧要。我只是这个过程中的一个齿轮。
What you need to do is make it illegal. Because if you don't make it illegal, the next guy will just come in here and do it. And if I do the right thing, I'll get fired. In order to make it illegal, there are hundreds of people working every day, maybe thousands, on what it takes to have ethical corporate organizations. And those people make slight improvements. I think we're living at a time where we've lost more ground than we've gained ground, but those things are hard to measure, and I would turn to the experts who are working on this, such as John Harrington, who has worked on ethical corporate investing with investments,
你需要做的是让它非法化。因为如果你不让它非法化，下一个人就会进来做同样的事。如果我做正确的事，我就会被解雇。为了使其非法化，每天有数百人，也许数千人，致力于如何建立合乎道德的企业组织。这些人做出了一些微小的改进。我认为我们生活在一个失去的阵地多于获得的阵地的时代，但这些事情很难衡量，我会求助于那些致力于此的专家，比如约翰·哈林顿，他一直致力于道德企业投资，
and I would ask him, are we making any headway? In the meantime, what I'm interested in is being able to bring about the political leadership who could really create the pressure on those larger institutional forms to make them more empathic toward all of humanity because corporations should really serve the human species and the ecosystem to make them just, sustainable, such that human beings get enough food to eat, that they have education, that they have a place in society where they belong, where there is ethical work for them to do. And these progressive values of mine are in the descent right now way too much. I'm going to assert my ideological values
我会问他，我们有进展吗？与此同时，我感兴趣的是能够带来政治领导力，真正对那些大型机构形式施加压力，使它们对全人类更具同理心，因为企业确实应该服务于人类和生态系统，使它们公正、可持续，这样人类就能获得足够的食物，拥有教育，在社会中有一席之地，有合乎道德的工作可做。而我这些进步的价值观现在正处于严重的衰退之中。我要坚持我的意识形态价值观，
and help the political left win more elections by getting the heck out of its head and into its heart and learning how to lead with feeling and story so we learn how to create enough cohesiveness on the left to win enough elections to get the political right to sit back down at the table to negotiate democracy's future rather than continuing to tear democracy apart. If we don't learn how to tell good, true stories, if we don't know- Or just stories at all. I haven't seen a story from the Democratic Party for a long time. I mean, but I think there is a tension between people who see themselves as kind of responsible or moderate or the adults in the room on the left and the people who can tell a story.
并帮助政治左派赢得更多选举，方法是让它从头脑中走出来，进入内心，学习如何以情感和故事来领导，这样我们就能学会如何在左派内部创造足够的凝聚力，赢得足够的选举，让政治右派重新回到谈判桌前，协商民主的未来，而不是继续撕裂民主。如果我们不学会如何讲述好的、真实的故事，如果我们不知道——或者根本不知道故事。我已经很久没有从民主党那里看到一个故事了。我的意思是，但我认为在那些自认为是负责任的、温和的或左派中成年人的人，与那些能讲故事的人之间存在一种张力。
I mean, there's almost a mistrust of somebody who can intuitively read the room and connect with a group of people from, you know, the central what the Democratic Party is, which goes back to the 60s. I mean, it goes back to Vietnam and the Chicago 7 and a lot of those guys. I mean, I'm not trying to say that they, I'm not picking anybody, this is a psychology point about their campaign, it's not a political one, I'm not really publicly forward with my politics, but I mean, Obama basically used a lot of kind of empty things without committing to specific stuff, you know, but then when I watched Clinton's campaign, like, she would get up and there was no story, it was like she would negotiate with herself, she'd be like, well, somebody said we should do this, but also that's too far.
我的意思是，几乎有一种对那些能直觉地读懂房间并与一群人建立联系的人的不信任，你知道，民主党的核心是什么，这可以追溯到60年代。我的意思是，这可以追溯到越南战争和芝加哥七君子以及那些人中的许多。我的意思是，我不是想说他们，我不是在针对任何人，这是一个关于他们竞选活动的心理学观点，而不是政治观点，我并没有真正公开我的政治立场，但我的意思是，奥巴马基本上使用了很多空洞的东西，而没有承诺具体的事情，你知道，但当我观看克林顿的竞选活动时，就像，她站起来，没有故事，就像她在和自己谈判，她会说，好吧，有人说我们应该这样做，但这太激进了。
So what if whatever? And it's like, this is a campaign rally. And a lot of what you were told was, well, go to the website and read the data on the page about the proposed bill, which is not a narrative. It's not a story at all. I agree. I agree. And I'm working to do something about that. I'll be teaching a class next Friday to graduate students of depth psychology, and the story I'll be telling is of the history of humanity
那么如果什么什么呢？就像，这是一场竞选集会。而你被告知的很多事情是，好吧，去网站阅读页面上关于拟议法案的数据，那不是叙事。那根本不是一个故事。我同意。我同意。我正在努力解决这个问题。下周五我将为深层心理学的研究生上一门课，我将讲述的故事是人类的历史，
and the way we have evolved successfully and our failures of evolution, Western civilization's successes and its failures, and how that leads us to this moment. And what are the opportunities of this moment? And the fact that we have the left, whether it be Obama or Biden or the Clintons or Elizabeth Warren or Bernie Sanders or dozens of dozens of other people who are successfully holding our democracy together, but they are problematically one-sided in terms of their intellect and they don't quite know how to embody the feeling level
以及我们成功进化的方式和我们进化的失败，西方文明的成功与失败，以及它是如何引领我们走到这一刻的。这一刻的机会是什么？事实上，我们有左派，无论是奥巴马、拜登、克林顿夫妇、伊丽莎白·沃伦还是伯尼·桑德斯，或者其他几十个人，他们成功地维持了我们的民主，但他们在智力方面存在问题，是片面的，他们不太知道如何体现情感层面，
and the intuition level to create the stories really does create a place at the table for the depth psychologist to step forward and into the role of helping. Now, Arianna Huffington in 2010 said, enough analysis. We need more to hear from more of the political pundit Carl Jung. Now, if that wasn't somebody pulling a chair out for us at the seat of cultural leadership, I don't know what was. The dilemma is I'm part of the international Jungian community, and as much as there are a few dozen of us trying to step into that seat, we don't quite know how to come out of our psychological story enough to get those people, the politicos,
以及直觉层面来创造故事，这确实为深层心理学家创造了一个站出来并发挥作用的空间。现在，阿里安娜·赫芬顿在2010年说，分析够了。我们需要更多地听到政治评论员卡尔·荣格的声音。现在，如果那不是有人在为我们拉开文化领导力的椅子，我不知道那是什么。困境在于我是国际荣格社区的一员，尽管有几十个人试图坐上那个位置，但我们不太知道如何从我们的心理故事中走出来，去让那些政客，
to show up at our conferences. We depth psychologists are really ready to do therapy with the world, but the world has not shown up for its first session. And that's on us psychologists for not getting out into social change organizations and talking to the politicos doing the trench work where they are. That's on us. Well, I mean, and kind of what I was asking about that failure to tell a story and, you know, just some of the like examples I've seen of that is like, don't you think that there is an inferiority complex beneath living in your head that much, that there's a fear of being, well, I won't look serious or I won't look smart or I won't look presidential. Like if I show any intuition, if I show any authenticity, if I even say what I believe in a way that isn't, you know, put the word salad, then I'm going to get in trouble.
出现在我们的会议上。我们深层心理学家确实准备好与世界进行治疗，但世界还没有参加它的第一次会议。这是我们心理学家的责任，因为我们没有走出去进入社会变革组织，也没有去与那些在战壕里工作的政客交谈。这是我们的责任。好吧，我的意思是，关于那种讲故事的失败，你知道，我看到的一些例子，你不觉得在你的头脑中生活得那么多之下有一种自卑情结吗？有一种恐惧，比如，我看起来不严肃，或者我不够聪明，或者我不够有总统风范。就像如果我表现出任何直觉，如果我表现出任何真实性，如果我甚至以一种不是，你知道，词汇沙拉的方式说出我的信仰，那么我就会惹上麻烦。
Let's do something about that. So back about 25 years ago, I did. Do you think that maybe that's wrong? I mean, what I'm asking about is a generation that's kind of older than me. I mean, you know, it's like, you know, those, do you see that trend, especially in the kind of liberal left, of, well, I have to. There's a reason for it. and we can do something about it. So let's do something about it. 25 years ago, I did some research and I got a bunch of folks that are activists and leaders from the political left and I sat them down and we talked about it.
让我们为此做点什么。所以大约25年前，我做了。你认为这可能错了吗？我的意思是，我问的是比我年长的一代。我的意思是，你知道，就像，你知道，那些，你看到那种趋势了吗，特别是在自由左派中，嗯，我必须这样做。这是有原因的。我们可以为此做点什么。所以让我们为此做点什么。25年前，我做了一些研究，我找了一群来自政治左派的活动家和领导人，我让他们坐下来，我们谈论了这件事。
And one of the things that came out is this prejudice against feeling. And one woman who was on the city council at the time spoke in the research circle about the way that she had been attacked at a public meeting and she had to go in the back room to cry because she couldn't dare show feeling in public. Well, I learned that 25 years ago and since then I've been helping community leaders and psychotherapists to reflect on that reality and to begin the work of doing something about it through training. We can train ourselves up. There are tens of thousands of good therapists around the country maybe a hundred thousand maybe a million i don't know and all of them could help community leaders develop their emotional intelligence and learn how to use it in public i call that the development of a very simple public emotional intelligence and once the left catches on to this, they will win more elections. And there are some politicos who are starting to do this more, but it's really hard.
其中一件事就是这种对情感的偏见。当时在市议会的一位女性在研究小组中谈到了她在一次公开会议上受到攻击的方式，她不得不去后台哭泣，因为她不敢在公共场合表现出情感。好吧，我在25年前就学到了这一点，从那时起，我一直在帮助社区领袖和心理治疗师反思这一现实，并开始通过培训来解决这个问题。我们可以训练自己。全国有成千上万的好治疗师，也许十万，也许一百万，我不知道，他们都可以帮助社区领袖发展他们的情商，并学习如何在公共场合使用它。我称之为发展一种非常简单的公共情商，一旦左派意识到这一点，他们就会赢得更多选举。有一些政客开始更多地这样做，但这真的很难。
People who are more right-identified identify with different values than those of us who are left-leaning. And the values they identify with are solid, important, good values. And those of us that are more liberal, the values we emphasize are different. And we serve a purpose and people on the right serve a purpose. And in a healthy democracy, the tension between the right and the left leads to good things. Now, our polarization has deteriorated the democratic process to the point where we are at risk for losing our democracy. And those of us on the left, I think we need to stop putting the right down in our overly simplified manner. Yeah.
那些更认同右派的人认同的价值观与我们这些左倾的人不同。他们认同的价值观是坚实的、重要的、好的价值观。而我们这些更自由派的人，我们强调的价值观是不同的。我们有我们的目的，右派也有他们的目的。在一个健康的民主国家，右派和左派之间的张力会带来好的结果。现在，我们的两极分化已经使民主进程恶化到我们面临失去民主的风险的地步。而我们这些左派，我认为我们需要停止以我们那种过度简单化的方式贬低右派。是的。
And those of us on the left really do, as you've said, need to learn how to tell effective stories that really are motivating and moving. And there are some people on the left who are better at that than others. Well, and I think that Freud called it the narcissism of petty differences. But what you have a ton on the left is people fighting about semantics, about language, about aesthetics. And I don't like people fighting about aesthetics at all. I mean, there was just an eight-year period where people were yelling like, well, I think the president should have bad manners. I think the president should have good manners. And I was like, I care about how many people are starving. I care about how much healthcare exists. I care about what our planet looks like. I care about how much money is going to this and not that. You know, I don't really care if he's reading Emily Post or not. That was just me. I really like how you put that.
而我们这些左派确实，正如你所说，需要学习如何讲述有效的、真正能激励和感人的故事。左派中有些人比其他人更擅长这一点。好吧，我认为弗洛伊德称之为“微小差异的自恋”。但左派中有很多关于语义、语言、美学的争论。我一点也不喜欢人们争论美学。我的意思是，过去八年里，人们一直在大喊大叫，比如，嗯，我认为总统应该有坏礼貌。我认为总统应该有好的礼貌。而我就想，我关心有多少人在挨饿。我关心存在多少医疗保健。我关心我们的星球看起来是什么样。我关心有多少钱花在这个而不是那个上。你知道，我真的不在乎他是否在读艾米莉·波斯特。那只是我。我真的很喜欢你这样表达。
Well, I think it's an inevitable process if you take away all the levers of power and you say, okay, well, it's too far to do this because that alienates this part of the Big Ten Democratic Party. Well, it's too far to do that because that's not reasonable anymore. We have corporate control. It's not the 70s. So there's no there's no power that you have. What's left other than the way things look and the way they sound, you know, because as there's less and less things that we're allowed to expect the president to do or the party to do, then there's less and less. Political correctness is what is killing the left. of small differences is a result of not having a shared story that catalyzes our movement toward engaging the political right in a way that brings everybody back to the table to
好吧，我认为如果你拿走了所有的权力杠杆，你说，好吧，做这个太激进了，因为那会疏远民主党大帐篷的这一部分。好吧，做那个太激进了，因为那不再合理了。我们有企业控制。现在不是70年代了。所以你没有任何权力。除了事情看起来的样子和听起来的样子，还有什么剩下的呢？你知道，因为随着我们被允许期望总统或政党做的事情越来越少，那么剩下的就越来越少。政治正确正在扼杀左派。微小差异的自恋是由于没有一个共同的故事来催化我们向接触政治右派的方向发展，从而使每个人都回到谈判桌前，
negotiate our shared future. We need a story that is about the human species' shared future on earth that accounts for where we will be in seven generations. The fact that species are dying off, the fact that glaciers are falling into the ocean, the fact that some of our children aren't going to have children because they don't think it's ethical to bring children into the world right now. We got to have a story that accounts for all of that. I happen to think the origin of that story needs to be on the political left going post-ideological and really expanding its psychological range to stop demonizing, to withdraw its projections, and to go hear a more potent center on the left. But that's because that's where I
协商我们共同的未来。我们需要一个关于人类在地球上共同未来的故事，它要考虑到七代人之后我们将会在哪里。物种正在灭绝的事实，冰川正在坠入海洋的事实，我们的一些孩子将不会有孩子的事实，因为他们认为现在把孩子带到这个世界上是不道德的。我们必须有一个考虑到所有这些的故事。我碰巧认为这个故事的起源需要在政治左派身上，走向后意识形态，真正扩展其心理范围，停止妖魔化，撤回其投射，并去听取左派中一个更有力的中心。但那是因为那是我想做工作的地方。我相信右派也有同样重要的工作要做。好吧，而且其中一些，我的意思是，这不是，我不是想攻击左派或右派。我的意思是，我认为更广泛地说，与此相关的是，我认为变革始于地方层面。然后如果你有更健康的当地社区，你开始更快地拥有这些社区的网络，而我们试图从上到下改变所有这些东西，就像负责整个系统的人或总统要进来改变它一样。他们确实有一些权力，
want to do my work. I'm sure there's equally important work to do on the right. Well, and some of, I mean, it's not, I'm not trying to punch left or right. I mean, what I'm saying, I think, more broadly is related to that is that I think that change begins at the local level. And then if you have healthier local communities and you begin to faster have a network of those communities, and we try and change all this stuff from the top down, like whoever's in charge of the whole system or the president's going to come in and change it. And they do have some power,
但我认为如果你要朝着你所说的方向取得真正的进步，在没有一个公正的社区的情况下，你知道，只是某个人在网上发布它，没有朋友，没有教会，没有世俗组织，没有，你知道，工作社区，没有那种地方社区，是根本行不通的。随着我们变得越来越数字化，我们真的忘记了这一点。我同意你的看法。在我的社区里正在发生的一件事，我的两个朋友，约翰·克劳利和卢，我总是很难记住他的姓氏，所以现在我很尴尬，但无论如何，卢和约翰在当地图书馆举办了一些叫做“佩塔卢马对话”的活动。
but I think that if you're going to make real progress in the direction that you're talking about, to do that without a community of just, you know, somebody online posting about it without any friends, without a church, without a secular organization, without, you know, a work community, without any kind of local community is something that just doesn't work. And we have forgotten that as we've become more digital, really. I agree with you. One of the things that is happening in my community, two friends of mine, John Crowley and Lou, I always have a hard time with his last name, and so now I'm embarrassed, but anyhow, Lou and John hold something called Petaluma Conversations at the local library.
他们带着几个非专业培训师出现。他们把一个政治议题写在卡片上，放在桌子上。然后社区里的人就会出现。他们已经这样做多年了。他们选择他们想坐在哪张桌子旁，哪个议题。在每张桌子上，都有一个培训师。他们轮流说话。当一个人说话两三分钟时，
And they show up with a handful of lay trainers. And they put a political issue on a card and set that card on a table. And then people from the community show up. They've been doing this for years. And they pick which issue, which table they want to sit at. And at each table, there's a trainer. And they take turns talking. And when one person talks for two or three minutes,
下一个人在发表自己的观点之前，会反思他们听到了什么。这很深刻。内在的传声筒游戏。是的，好吧。这很深刻。内在的传声筒游戏。是的，好吧，这很深刻。所以我不能站起来说我的观点，直到我证明了我非常仔细地听了上一个说话的人。这太聪明了。
the next person reflects what they heard before they say their piece. It's profound. The inner telephone game. Yeah, well. It's profound. The inter-telephone game. Yeah, well, it's profound. So I don't get to stand up and say my opinions until I've demonstrated that I listened really closely to the last person who spoke. That's pretty brilliant.
这很聪明。确实如此。卢还在帮助当地，他帮助发起了当地的“勇敢天使”组织分会，他们把红蓝公民聚集在一起，引导他们进行高度心理纪律的练习，学习如何倾听以及如何跨越红蓝差异进行沟通。上帝保佑他这样做。我想我没有那个胃口。约翰也是一个叫做“佩塔卢马明天”组织的一部分。不，佩塔卢马，“酷佩塔卢马”，它获得了一百万美元的赠款，帮助佩塔卢马降低其碳足迹。
It's brilliant. It truly is. Lou is also helping the local, he helped start the local Braver Angels organization chapter, and they bring red and blue citizens together and step them through highly psychologically disciplined practices of how to listen and how to communicate across the red-blue difference. And bless his heart for doing that. I don't think I have the stomach for that. And John is also part of an organization called Petaluma Tomorrow. No, Petaluma, Cool Petaluma, that got a million-dollar grant to help Petaluma lower its carbon footprint.
他们正在挨家挨户地走，培训每个社区的志愿者，关于如何与邻居谈论哪些做法会降低每个社区的碳足迹。他们正在使用……约翰和卢都不是心理治疗师。卢是一名受过培训的调解员，约翰的背景是计算机工程。他们已经接受了反思性倾听练习的培训，并正在将这些练习带入他们的社会变革组织中。如果未来存在，这就是它将展开的方式之一。通过我们这些受过心理学培训的人，在我们的社区中更加活跃，并帮助我们的社区发展他们解决这些差异所需的宽容、耐心和谦逊。这是可能的，而且正在发生。而且，有一个家伙，嗯，他在2000年代初做过所有这些，呃，就像我记不起名字了，因为他是一个，嗯，像一个活动家和某种政治艺术家，但他会，呃，去这些社区，这些小城镇，谈论像气候
And they're going neighborhood by neighborhood and training volunteers in every neighborhood as to how to talk to their neighbor about what practices will lower each neighborhood's carbon footprint. And they're using neither John nor Lou are psychotherapists. Lou's a trained mediator and John's background is in computer engineering. And they have trained themselves in reflective listening practices and they're bringing those into their social change organizations. If there is a future, this is one of the ways it will unfold. Through those of us with psychological training, getting more active in our communities and helping our communities develop the tolerance, the patience and the humility that they need to work out these differences. And it is possible and it is happening right and there there was a a guy um who used to do in like the early 2000s all of this uh like i'm blanking on the name because he was he was a um like an activist and kind of a political artist but he he would uh go to these communities these small towns and talk about like climate
变化和核武器以及风险的数量，金钱的数量。而且，你知道，他会被大声喊叫打断。所以后来他就不做了，他会回到同一个城镇，他以为人们会认出他，但他们没有。他会做一个不同的项目，就像，好吧，看，你，这个城镇有400万美元，它只是得到，你知道，这个县，你用它做什么？每年你得到400万美元，他们就像，哦，建一所学校。我们会做这个，什么的。他会回来，就像，好吧，那很好。但你已经花掉了。你不能每年都建一所学校。明年你打算用这400万美元做什么？他们就像，好吧，我的意思是，我们可以修路，他就像，好吧，那是基础设施。所以那也消失了。你已经
change and nuclear weapons and the amount of uh risk the amount of money. And, you know, he would kind of get shouted down. And so then he quit doing it and he would go back to the same towns and he thought the people would kind of recognize him and they didn't. And he would do a different project and be like, okay, look, you, this town has $4 million that it just gets, you know, this county, what do you do with it? Every year you get $4 million and they're like, Oh, build a school. We'll do this, whatever. And he would come back and be like, okay, that's great. But you already spent it. You can't build a school every year. What are you going to do with the $4 million next year? And they're like, well, I mean, we could do roads and he's like, okay, that's infrastructure. So that's gone too. You've
做过了。你不需要再做20年了。你用这400万美元做什么？然后他们会开始像，这笔钱是从哪里来的？他就像，好吧，你知道，我们有核能力把世界炸毁30次。但即使我们需要，我们真的只需要炸毁它一次。所以如果你只是摆脱了炸毁世界的能力，你知道，29倍冗余次数，你知道，你只是有所有这些额外的钱。所以无论如何，你会把它花在什么上面？然后他们会生气，他们就像，什么？为什么我们做？
already done it. You don't need to do that for another 20 years. What do you do with the $4 million? And then they would start being like, what is this money coming from? And he's like, well, you know, we have the nuclear capacity to blow up the world 30 times. But even if we need to, we really just need to blow it up once. So like if you just got rid of the ability to blow up the world, you know, 29 X redundant times, you know, you just have all this extra money. So anyway, what would you spend it with? And then they get angry and they're like, what? Why do we do?
我们可以有四百万美元。就像，然后人们就像对他大喊大叫，你知道，我认为那种对社区的呼吁和这些东西的直接影响，这就是为什么我认为当你开始说，你知道，与物质脱节的价值观，那就是它们危险的地方，你知道，像那样的事情正在建立如此直接的联系，你知道，与心弦，而不是，而不是，你知道，我们的自我价值观。好吧，我喜欢这个主意，我喜欢这个主意，嗯，你知道，呼吁钱包，显然，但也只是，嗯，让社区反思他们的需求是什么，呃，看到我们目前组织的方式和我们目前被组织的价值观，
We could have four million dollars. Like and then the people were like yelling at him you know i think that kind of appeal to community and the direct effect of this stuff which is why i think when you start saying you know values disconnected from the material that's where they're dangerous you know something like that is making such a direct connection you know to the heartstrings and not the and not the you know our ego values well i like the idea i like the idea of um you know appealing to the pocketbook obviously but also just um having communities reflect on what their needs are and uh seeing that the way we currently are organized and the values that were currently
是过去时代的宿醉，所以无论是心理治疗，你必须帮助某人只是对他们的童年如何影响他们当前的生活和他们当前的关系有洞察力，或者如果你帮助一个社区做同样的事情，这些事情是可能的，它可以释放能量，或者它可以释放金钱，或者两者兼而有之。好吧，而且你让某人立即参与到一个关于世界如何变得更好的更好愿景中，而不告诉他们，你知道，这看起来很屈尊俯就，或者对此有反应。在这里，他们只是在设想，如果我有400万美元会怎样？
organized by our hangovers from a past time so whether it's psychotherapy you had to help somebody just have insights about how their childhood affects their current life and their current relationships or if you help a community do the same these things are possible and it can free up energy or it can free up money or both well and you're having somebody immediately participate in a better vision of how the world could be better without telling them that, you know, and which seems condescending or there's reaction to it. Here, they're just envisioning, what if I had $4 million?
这对我的孩子来说是什么样子的？这对道路来说是什么样子的？这对什么什么来说是什么样子的？然而，你知道，因为他们感觉到了。而且我认为你得到最多阻力的地方，左派和右派，就是如果你只是说，嘿，如果另一方不是那么糟糕会怎样，嗯，如果，如果另一方的解决方案，像，不是那么糟糕，只是两者都不是那么好，如果我们可以稍微相信一个更好的可能世界会怎样？对那个有如此负面的反应，他们就像，你为什么让民主党人脱钩？你为什么让共和党人脱钩？你一定是在秘密地为他们工作，或者你一定不知道我在Facebook上找到的这个可怕的事实列表。就像，不，我只是说也许有一个稍微
What does that look like for my kids? What does that look like for the road? What does that look like for whatever? Whereas, you know, because they're feeling it. And I think one of the places where you get the most pushback left and right is if you just say hey what if the other side's not that terrible um what if what if the other side's solution like is is not that terrible it's just that neither one is really that great what if we could just slightly believe in a better possible world such a negative reaction to that they're like why are you letting the democrats off the hook why are you letting the republicans off the cook you must secretly be working for them, or you must not know this list of terrible facts I found on Facebook. And it's like, no, I'm just saying maybe there's a slightly
更好的做事方式。而我们美国人对此有立即的愤怒、负面反应。等等，等等，等等。我不认为那是真的，不足以跟随。有些人确实那样反应。所以你的陈述是真的，但它也是一个漫画。我发现作为一个漫画，它走得太远了。因为这也是真的，我发现当我与人交谈时，如果我有耐心，我不必有耐心那么久，但当我耐心时，人们愿意缓和对话。人们愿意更多地谈论他们在情感上来自哪里。这给了我很大的希望，人们想要在他们被有效关注时找到彼此最好的一面。所以这就是我所做的，我培训社区领袖和崭露头角的治疗师，
better way to do things. And we have Americans have an immediate angry, negative reaction to that. Hold on, hold on, hold on. I don't think that's true enough to follow. Some people do react that way. So your statement is true, but it's also a caricature. And I find as a caricature, it goes too far. Because it's also true that I find when I talk to people that if I'm patient, and I don't have to be patient that long, but when I'm patient, people are willing to de-escalate conversations. People are willing to talk more about where they're coming from emotionally. And that gives me a great deal of hope that people want to find the best in each other when they are attended to effectively. And so what I do is I train community leaders and budding therapists,
如何使用那些在从心理病理学痛苦中创造治愈方面非常有效的心理治疗技能，但也致力于创造我们在社区中需要的关系类型。我对这一点有很大的信心，当人们被倾听时，他们会停止指责他人。好吧，而且我不是，你知道，我不是说我对人类没有信心或尊重。我的意思是，我谈论的很多是一个越来越大的，你知道，也许是一个少数群体，但它越来越大的一群非常政治反应激烈的美国人，他们非常情绪化，非常不安，但我认为那些人如果你要建立你谈论的项目，将会非常重要，所以我想的是，你如何接触他们，你知道，嗯，
how to use the psychotherapy skills that work so well to create healing from psychopathological suffering, but also work to create the type of relationships we need in our communities. And I have a great deal of faith in that, that when people are listened to, they stop pointing fingers at others. Well, and I'm not, you know, I'm not saying that I have no faith or respect for humanity. I mean, a lot of what I'm talking about is an increasingly large, you know, maybe it's a minority, but it's increasingly getting larger group of very politically reactive Americans that are very emotional and very upset and I but those people are going to be incredibly important if you're gonna build the project you're talking about and so kind of what I'm thinking about is how do you reach them you know um
好吧，我会告诉你，我想我知道当有两极分化时，你想告诉每个在手臂范围内的人，只有那些在你的手臂范围内的人，不要试图告诉，不要试图为每个人想象一个单一的故事，但那些你可以接触到的人，无论是这个播客，在你的社区，在你的诊所，还是无论哪里，那些你可以接触到的人，帮助他们看到两极分化是正常的。当你痛苦时，关闭边界是正常的。并帮助他们转变对话，以一种新的方式谈论他们自己的痛苦。好吧，我认为其中一种方式，继续。工作，它有效。
well I'll tell you I think I know when there's polarization you want to tell everybody within arms reach only the people that are within your arms reach don't try to tell don't try to imagine a single story for everybody but those people you can reach whether it's this podcast, in your neighborhood, in your clinic, or wherever, those people you can reach out to, help them see that it's normal to polarize. It's normal to close boundaries when you're distressed. And help them shift the conversation to talk in a new way about their own distress. Well, I think one of the ways, go ahead. Work, it works.
好吧，我的意思是，我发现这样做的方式，我的意思是，我想这将是那些，你知道，我这个年龄和更年轻的人，通过有一点，嗯，有一点幽默感，也许对自己，其他人的政治有一点自嘲，那种愚蠢，这有点像我正在尝试做的，而且，而且坐在那里，人们撤回了投射，你知道，他们撤回了阴影的投射，在这里，还有在这里宏伟的、美妙的救世主爸爸妈妈，所以我不是，你知道，而且我，我认为其中一些，特别是当你处理年轻一代时，我的意思是，我不是想取笑任何人想什么，或者让他们感觉不好，只是说，像，我
Well, I mean, the way that I've found to do that, which I mean, I guess is going to be people that are, you know, my age and younger is by being a little bit um having a little bit of a sense of humor maybe being a slightly self-deprecating about my politics other people's politics kind of the silliness of that which is sort of what i'm trying to do and and sitting with that people withdraw the projection you know they withdraw the projection of the shadow over here and the grandiose wonderful savior daddy mommy over here and and so i'm not you know and i i think some of that especially when you're dealing with younger generations i mean i'm not trying to make fun of it what anybody thinks or make them feel bad just saying like i
知道我们变得非常不安，脸都变蓝了，大喊大叫，我们为此哭泣，无论什么，这有点愚蠢，我们能有一点幽默感吗？你知道，对我们如何思考有一点幽默感，以便感觉不那么重要？乔尔，我和你在一起。我很好奇我们如何结束这次对话。因为在这一点上，我需要去吃点早餐。当然，不。我们真的，真的非常感谢你的时间。
know we get really upset and turn blue in the face and yell and we cry about it and whatever it's kind of stupid like can we just have a little bit of a sense of humor you know that the have some humor about how we think in order to feel a little bit less important? Joel, I'm with you. And I'm curious about how we wind this conversation up. What would, because at this point, I need to go have some breakfast. Sure, no. We really, really appreciate your time.
和你交谈非常迷人。任何你想要结束或推广的东西，我一定会把它放在节目的展示说明中。我们只是，我不知道，拥有两套不同的语言或两个不同的意识形态镜头，看看它们是如何结合在一起的，这真的很整洁。所以我总是欣赏像这样的对话。好吧，我认为只是在结束时，我认为工作是学习如何使用心理学视角或心理学态度，
It's been fascinating talking to you. And anything that you kind of want to close on or promote, I'll definitely throw in the show notes of the show. And we just, I don't know, it's really neat to kind of have two different sets of language or two different ideological lenses and see how those come together. So I always appreciate conversations like this one. Well, I think just in closing, I think the work is to learn how to use the psychological perspective or a psychological attitude
以一种更广泛的方式，真正能够解释社会和政治，但不要仅仅以批评任何意识形态的失败的名义来做。我们这些受过心理学和政治训练的人有责任阐明一种手段。我们有责任识别与它们相关的社会和政治问题以及心理健康问题，这些问题目前困扰着我们，并不仅仅是批评。我们实际上有责任制定一个补救措施。为了，你知道，一个可以在诊所或私人诊所办公室或教室或市议会会议厅或餐桌或国家新闻媒体或国家之间进行的共同实践。
in a more expansive way to really be able to account for the social and the political, but not to do it solely in the name of critiquing the failures of any ideology. Those of us that have psychological and political training are responsible for articulating a means to an end. We're responsible for identifying the social and political problems and the mental health issues linked to them that are currently haunting us and doing more than criticize. we're actually responsible for developing a remedy. For you know, a shared practice that can take place in the clinic or the private practice office or the classroom or the city council chamber or the dining room table or in the national news media, or between nations.
我们有责任阐明一个故事，它能够在所有这些地方容易地、相当容易地讲述关于我们共同人性的故事。关于现在是时候通过牺牲和一些共同责任和谦逊的经验将我们重新聚集在一起，为了世界上正在发生的事情，为了将我们从边缘拉回来，给我们一点喘息的空间，并为我们争取一些时间，以便我们能够真正看到我们的问题在多大程度上是有解决方案的。它们始于正确的、有效的心理学故事，它是关于我们所有人以及所有人共同努力的。是的，好吧，非常感谢你的时间，彼得，那太美了。谢谢。感谢观看！这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
We're responsible for articulating a story that is able to be told readily and somewhat easily in all of those places about our shared humanity. And about now is the time to bring ourselves back together through sacrifice and some experience of shared duty and humility for the sake of what's happening in the world, for the sake of pulling ourselves back from the brink to give us a little breathing room and to buy us some time so that we can really see the extent to which there are solutions to our problem. And they begin with the right, right effective psychological story that is about all of us and all working together yeah well thank you so much for your time peter that's beautiful Thank you. Thanks for watching! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们有责任去阐述一个故事，一个能够在所有这些地方被轻松且顺畅地讲述的关于我们共同人性的故事。现在正是时候，为了世界上正在发生的事情，为了让我们从边缘拉回来，为了给我们一点喘息的空间，为了争取一些时间，让我们能够真正看到我们的问题在多大程度上是有解决办法的，我们需要通过牺牲以及对共同责任和谦逊的体验，重新团结在一起。而这一切都始于一个正确且有效的心理叙事，一个关于我们所有人以及共同努力的故事。好的，非常感谢你的时间，彼得，这太美好了。谢谢。感谢观看！本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。